erskine so sports friends is a game by
Goethe fabric and this it's for local
multiplayer games for controllers and
for people plant you next to play with
less controllers and for people because
you can do like a sharesies thing all of
them are two player except for hawk
round two to four players except for
Harper yeah i think is requires four
players we are giving away copies of
sports friends as well follow us at
twitter twitter Jesus I've gamespot on
Twitter use the hashtag GS lobby and
make sure you're following us so we can
send you the codes the a direct message
Chris waters what game we played what
should we start with here I really wanna
play soccer oh good Danny wants to play
Hawker this is a pretty simple one to
understand it's a world cup here so
we're gonna start with this basically
it's gonna be me and marry against you
you guys oh man we got a green all the
way team carnage Mary we both played
this game before and they haven't I
think we can I played this game two
years ago alright so basically just
someone press X everyone for sex got it
oh this is a two button game left analog
stick to move around X to like speed
boost when you don't have the ball you
boost into someone to grab the ball from
them get the ball into your colored zone
to score points and I'm most points wins
i'll hit you gotta hit the ball in ok
it's soccer with two goals I understand
double sweet go they go right into ours
I understand double switch better
backers down over there over there
calling me but y'all know your savings
and green oh you have to score it into
your own better so i got i threw back to
on karnak's carnage don't ok go kick it
to me kick to me I'm stole it from there
yeah the key is to stay stay separated
and then going to ours oh yeah got it
what a rocket back to you go into the
corner are you gonna hold in the green
hold on your grant you you got one did
that happen or no [ __ ] the Lord oh I
tried to pass it but they were oh not
sure why it did that but I did carnage
you go go I'm gonna keep it in there
keep it in high I didn't even know ok
I'm sure I understand this a little bit
better yo oh come down all you get that
out of there in their points you pieces
all right that's it what fast you gotta
give it a kid in there all right give it
there and give me regular Oh
I got it I'm gonna top right how's it
guys don't go exes turbo by the way
don't go ahead guys top right is not a
cool place I got it I got I got it I'm
liking Rinaldo of being a cube over
there burn awful good number three they
go they go i snag I should isn't your
step Danny just throw it they go come on
it's all about teamwork this is like
when you're playing football as a kid
and you're like super high school kids
and every wonderful at the same time oh
I'm really confused I think I'm
nearsighted after experiencing that I
realized I need glasses are terrible all
right different game all right well new
game it's burned through these yeah odd
we'll work our way up to the most
complicated which is very very more okay
also we'll do a quick match bull rider
yeah speaking of games that Sam like
pornos 4-pole riders who are we
volunteers y'all don't say volunteers
all right the old bollocks I are bears
bears let's just be bared team bear go
mommy death grip Gert are you make her
walk hold stone Heather who clop all
right go ah cool let me see if I move
yourself back and forth right stick
rotates your pole all the way around
yeah I want to rotate my pole Chris
waters I believe you Danny you guys some
years experience wait what am I how am I
controlling this what is this about
choose choose it forget i feel like it's
better if you don't know I really don't
know all right so let's see your figure
out which guy you are now use your Pole
defend yourself around and push that
ball target to the right okay and how do
I do that just rotate the pole a bunch
it's gotta rotate your poem at oh come
on you turned out you should get away
from me number three know your role and
shut your pole oh you just go that was
it I scored fruit yeah I scored for you
guys you start an own poll it's I would
get in a lot of trouble if I were to do
that somewhere else sure you would ya
got a world cup 1991
I'm gonna yeah I know watch out just
moving it along oh wow I got kicked in
the face oh it's me versus one come on
Danny do a stand Danny do it no oh no
bring it bring it bring it bring it man
you gotta get out of here we got to go
to kill ya no not gonna not gonna happen
i'm just gonna hit ah I'm just gonna
move him I'm gonna spike this gonna
spike what come on I'm kicking you right
now how do i jump Paul you john-boy
yourself I'm pulling month get out of
here wait oh yeah exactly you didn't
know who's going on there come on Danny
come on thank you I live alone Chris
waters I know how to pull myself ah I
believe you daddy let him drop we look
at you ride a pole come on come on Danny
let's do it we got it we got it we got
any getting Chris you got it Oh defense
d I'm blocking him down dad go daddy God
yeah keep it up keep it going anybody
Sean mice long enough so I can you for
kicking it yeah I got to my Gotham I got
some John John go for it you go for it
John you got nothing do it haha think so
all right good right here hold up write
it whoa come on hold my defense come on
Danny squishing me against the wall now
it's just you and waters no this is not
the broad yeah almost done I polish dog
[ __ ] not you catch the case Tommy got
this Charlie gothic I don't know how to
get the ball yeah they can pull the
other way like it I'll grant you there
we go get it Danny get it no no yes come
on dad
oh man this is a game right here I'm
talking about better than all that
psychedelic colors and stuff that were
playing before the hell's that no I
kicked me you're gonna keep going keep
out of here I'm get it out here yeah now
we're talking they go oh I'm running I'm
old I'm doing home a defense go okay go
for go for everyone yeah some [ __ ] you
son no no yes we got relish it the
equalizer this is it this serious
cheaters just like Gunnar Nelson get in
get any son of a drop down onto your
heads oh oh oh yeah yes the murder it's
all we had was just me right Danny a
wonderful providing dirty alone no lo n
well what's wrong every single time she
yes ever since I got back from Iceland
all I've done is loose I was losing a
nice one too oh look at you two bears
just hugging whatever your loser embrace
all right final match Oh final game is
bara berry ball hmm are we skipping a oh
yeah we can't do this is it just is a
bigger space and a lot of music playing
type and type environment this is like a
DVD it's a little bit like smash
brothers except you're trying to get the
ball into the opponent's into the ocean
it is colored that same colors you all
right let's try not suck so hard at this
one can we be po po let me hope oh you
gotta be po po all right so X is jump
kick it squares attack the circles
around you are the amount of jumps you
have if you run out of jumps and you
fall if you fall into the ocean at all
ready I was a point all right okay I was
listening to the instructions man oh you
got your game face on and on I I'm ready
you want to lose like you did to the
Icelandic do you are the same time where
they go true get the gun Sita could see
your color and the the ocean color yeah
you would like it you need to get the
Gupta ball into the green ocean in order
to get a point we need to get it into
what oranges so wait get the block in a
pool they got a point
I think we already know what's gonna
happen here at this point is ball yeah
that's the fetus attitude son of a [ __ ]
not expect that I'm just gonna go oh how
do you hit people ask where where is
your mainland doing see how you're out
of who you hit me when you when you're
red like that you're out of jumps and
you don't want i got order when you're
at a jump okay so you're just jump in
the water with the ball yeah are you
just throw it in the water get it you
can dunk it all the way down yeah you're
gonna go let's happening what yeah you
fall in you lose a point Danny don't
fall in the water on more mad stay out
of that water get the ball stay out of
that water I'm not there you go you go
show them here yeah yeah don't in Duncan
Duncan wrong target just snag it wait
are you blowing that you losing all
these points when you dunk it man I know
anybody detected Duncan they didn't
count you have very upset balsa join
their yo you no no don't down on the
damn water all right just let it go let
it go I'm trying to recover it but then
that's stupid talk oh oh oh now sausage
I running low on jumps you can uh got
down oh maybe that's good that's good
recovering it to throw it in that water
oh yeah this is inconvenient for you but
no I can't let that happen hmm just
chuck it down here oh do you slam by
head down you would do it dude pass the
ball tore it down there Oh sunfish haha
oh this is the one right here this is
all the game needed to be was there oh
and he's done LOL very a punchy watch
out watch out let it go let it go
there's two are you going come on man so
used to losing
oh wow all right well no one enjoyed
that no I certainly did no one's friends
us if you want us every single time man
listen listen guys bring me here as a
guest to lose oh I want to consult you
guys Mary and I played this for about an
hour yesterday on multiple players on
livestream whea we are seasoned sports
friends so you know the guys your
friendship just isn't that the sports
level yet it's okay you've got you've
got a good thing going here where's
important to me you couldn't get worse
about it'll be buddies one day he and I
will grow yeah we're not yeah we r
sports enemies